als daniela gast am sonntag nach hause
in rudolstadt in thüringen an kam
erlebte sie einen schock katze minka
hockte im blutverschmierten keller
geschrieben
dem musiker wurden beide hinter tatzen
brutal abgehackt dass die er überlebte
nur knapp
weil die besitzerin minka schnell zum
tierarzt brachte und haben da könnte die
stimmung erhalten die eigentlich weg
sollten welche waren ja mit schmutz und
dreck und den doktor haus buck ist es
dann doch gelohnt
also wir haben alles gegeben hat alles
gewinnen was noch übrig fortsetzen
die reinigung heißen und intensiven
verschlossen was genau mit der katze
passiert ist weiß familie gestern nicht
weiß ein unfall oder wurde minka mit
einer axt angegriffen
wir hoffen eigentlich es stellt sich
raus das ist ein unfall war es kein
gutes gefühl einer umgebung zu geben
wurde offensichtlich zunächst
nachbarschaften schwer psychisch
gestörter mensch ist da katzen die pläne
für hinweise die zur ergreifung des
täters führen
selbst die familie eine belohnung von
über 1000 euro aus
[Musik]
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren